[Music]
if you want to be productive with
flutter one of the first things you
should master is layouts in today's
video I'll show you the core principles
for aligning and positioning widgets and
if your web developer I'll be making
direct comparisons to CSS because the
two share a lot more similarities than
you might realize if you new here like
and subscribe and you can grab the full
source code from fire ship i/o and I'll
be giving away another t-shirt with this
video all you have to do is leave a
comment below letting me know what you
want to see next the first thing we'll
look at is individual widget positioning
which is the equivalent to a div and
HTML with a CSS class applied to it from
there we'll look at how to layout
widgets and columns and rows which works
in the same way that flexbox does in CSS
and lastly we'll look at how to stack
wood just on top of each other which is
similar to absolute or fixed positioning
in CSS let's go ahead and jump into the
code and you'll see that I'm starting
out here with a scaffold which basically
gives us a point pallet to work with
then as the body I'm defining a
container that has a red border that'll
make it easy to visualize how child
elements fit within their parent
container then I've created a widget
called square which just has a fixed
width and height and we can pass in an
argument to adjust the size or the color
of the square this just gives us
something to work with as we start
aligning multiple items and quick
sidenote you'll notice I'm using font
awesome icons highly recommended if you
get bored with the default material
icons and then lastly we have a widget
called demo which we'll get to when we
start doing things with flexbox and
absolute positioning for now let's go
back up to the root container that we
define in the body you'll see that it's
sitting in the top left corner of the
view a container is a lot like a span or
a div and HTML in the sense that it's
just an empty piece of UI that you can
apply styles and positioning to let's
first add some spacing on the outside of
this element by setting a margin with
edge in sets to all sides of 24 and we
can increase that a bit to make it a
little more clear but basically it's
like putting an invisible border around
the entire container and up with the
equivalent CSS in the top right corner
here you can also set padding which will
put that invisible spacing on the inside
of the element so you'll notice that the
border gets pushed out and now the green
background on the container element is
visible you can apply spacing to
individual sides by using only instead
of all another thing you can set on a
widget is its alignment if we set the
alignment to Center for example it will
expand the widget out as far as it can
go until something tells it to stop
and it
place the child element directly in the
center the alignment behavior really
depends on the parent container in our
case it's going to expand out until it
hits the edge of the screen there's a
couple of other things you can do with
containers as well for example you can
explicitly set the width and the height
that's exactly what I've done to create
this square box in the middle and you
can also apply a transform to a
container that could be a whole video on
its own but you can do the same things
you can do in CSS like rotate skew and
scale I'd also like to point out that
flutter has a bunch of alternative
widgets instead of a container such as
padding and a line and they're useful
because a lot of times you won't need
all the functionality of a container if
you only need to apply padding you can
just use the patti-anne widget and that
will make your code more focused and
readable now let's move on to what's
probably the most important part of this
video flexible positioning it allows you
to align items and columns and rows
which takes care of the majority of the
layouts that you'll see on most mobile
apps for example if we wanted to rebuild
this layout on duolingo we would start
by defining a column then inside this
column we can stack multiple widgets in
this case we'd start with a text widget
and then we could add a row and then
another row for the buttons at the
bottom and if you look closely at the
middle row you'll notice we have another
column in there that stacks some
additional text widgets on top of each
other so basically we can nest columns
and rows to build a complex UIs and we
can wrap any of these in their own
container to fine tune their individual
alignment and positioning let's look at
some examples the first thing we'll do
is define a row and it will take an
argument of children which is an array
of widgets in the case of a row the
widgets will flow from left to right
horizontally you'll notice the row takes
up as much horizontal space as it
possibly can this is known as the main
axis so in the case of a row the main
axis will be the x-axis and a column is
actually identical to a row the only
difference is the axis is flipped so the
main axis becomes the y-axis this is
identical to how things work with CSS
flexbox so if you already comfortable a
flexbox then you're already going to be
comfortable with flutter positioning
Drizzt with a few name changes so if we
change our row to a column you can see
that now the items flow from top to
bottom and the extra space is along the
y-axis there's really only a couple of
options that you need to be familiar
with the first one is main axis size by
default it will take up the maximum
amount of space but if you set this to
min then you can see that it only goes
to the end of the child elements most of
the actual alignment will be adjusted
with the main axis alignment or the
cross axis alignment the main axis is
similar to justify content and CSS and
the cross axis alignment is similar to
align items for example if we use main
axis alignment space between it will
push the children towards the edges and
then try to maximize the space in
between them there's a lot of other
options like spaced evenly which will
just maximize the space evenly
throughout all the elements and we can
always flip this to a row and you can
see the only thing that changes is the
axis of alignment on the cross axis the
elements will be aligned in the middle
by default it helps if we have squares
of different sizes so you can see here
that they're all aligned directly in the
center but what if we want these to be
aligned at the start of the container we
can make that happen by setting the
cross axis alignment to the start of the
container or if we want to push them to
the opposite side we can set that to end
and one other cool thing you can do with
the cross axis is set it to stretch and
that will force the elements to expand
across the entire available space and
one other thing I want to point out is
that columns and rows are just
convenience widgets for the Flex widget
if you use a flex which--it you can
manually set the direction to either
axis horizontal or axis vertical so at
this point we've been controlling the
Flex behavior of the children via the
parent row or column but a lot of times
you'll need the actual child to define
its Flex behavior to demonstrate this
I'm going to give our boxes different
colors and one of the most common use
cases is when you have a set of widgets
and you want one of those widgets to
expand to the available space and have
the other widgets just be a fixed size
so for example we might want our last
widget to fill up this available space
while keeping the other ones the same
size we can easily do this by wrapping
our widget in the expanded widget and
this will tell it to flex to the
available space this is similar to the
Flex grow property and CSS and this is
actually a ratio that will be calculated
based on the other sibling elements next
to it currently this is the only
expanded widget so it's just going to
fill up all of the available space but
let's go ahead and wrap the middle
square in the expanded widget as well
for now we'll also set its Flex property
to one so since they're both set to one
they'll evenly share the available space
but the thing to remember here is that
the Flex property is a ratio so if we
set Flex 10 for the middle element and
flex 1 for the last element the middle
element will take up 10 times more space
than the last one in other words we
could fit 10 pink
widgets inside of the blue widget so
flexbox is awesome when working with
two-dimensional layouts but sometimes
you want things to overlap as if there
was a third dimension to work with for
that we're going to look at the flutter
stack and a common use case might be
something like a tooltip that gets
positioned relative to a button but on
top of the main view you can compare
stacks and flutter roughly to absolutely
or fix positioning and CSS let's go
ahead and grab our existing column and
convert it to a stack you'll notice that
it only displays one Square and that's
the Red Square which is the last one in
the array the other squares didn't
disappear they're just underneath the
Red Square the last element in the array
gets the highest priority when being
displayed if we make the Blue Square
last then it's the one that gets
displayed when we reload now that we
have our elements in a stack we need to
align or position them one way to do
that is with the align widget which
allows us to place elements relative to
the parent container in a perfect
position so it makes it really easy to
Center things and if you don't want to
use the align widget you can just use a
container and set the alignment there
when thinking about alignment the middle
is always going to be the zero zero
coordinate and you can control the
alignment directly if the built in
static methods aren't enough for example
if we set it to negative one negative
one it puts the Blue Square in the
top-left corner and if we were to set it
to zero zero it would be directly in the
middle but there's generally a better
way to position things when you're
working within a stack and that's with
the positioned widget this allows you to
define specific values relative to the
parent container based on top bottom
left right and one key difference that
you'll notice is that position won't
push the container element to the
furthest bounds that it's allowed to go
so in order for position to work you
need to have a container that already
has some free space available so I'm
wrapping the stack in a container and
then I'm manually setting the height and
width to be the size of the actual
device height and width from there I'll
go down to my positioned widgets and set
the top and left properties and now we
can see the parts of the other squares
that were hidden before and now just
like absolute position and CSS we can
move these boxes around wherever we want
so using a combination of containers
columns rows and stacks will take care
of the vast majority of your layout
needs in flutter let's go ahead and
bring everything together by running
through a full example of a card you
might build from scratch there's already
a material card built into flutter so
this is kind of redundant but it's a
good example anyway so we start with a
container
in that container we'll give it some
margin padding and we'll also give it a
border and you could also add a box
shadow here as well so basically we're
just adding styles to the box that will
hold our column and in the column itself
we'll have the cross axis alignment set
to stretch so it expands throughout the
entire card and main axis men will
ensure that the column only expands to
the content and not to the end of the
viewport now if we had children to this
container
they'll be stretched out across the
horizontal axis and that's how we get
this purple rectangle here and I didn't
really talk about text in this video but
they have their own specific text styles
that are also very similar to CSS now
because we're inside of a column these
text widgets will be stacked on top of
each other the next thing we'll do is
create another container and the child
of this container will be a row we want
to display three buttons horizontally
and we want the first button to be at
the very left and the last button to be
at the very right so for that we can use
main axis alignment space between then
we'll just go ahead and drop a few of
flutters built-in buttons into this
array and they'll be perfectly spaced
along the horizontal axis so as you can
see once you're comfortable at flexbox
it becomes very easy to prototype out
UIs and most of your layout should be
responsive and be able to adapt to
different viewport sizes in future
videos I'd like to clone popular mobile
app you eyes like maybe lyft or
Instagram or maybe even snapchats
redesign that everybody hates so if you
have any ideas let me know in the
comments I'm gonna go ahead and wrap
things up there look forward to more
flutter videos thanks for watching and I
will talk to you soon
[Music]